the biggest lesson you've learned from
internet fame what would it be
be yourself
[ __ ] the internet be yourself
the internet is filled with a lot of
untrue things
you know the internet is a fake world
it's not real
you may see real things that are
actually happening yeah be yourself be
yourself because it can let it consume
you you can let anyone can take over you
and consume you so be yourself thoughts
on that ladies because a lot of ladies
out there won't be themselves on the
internet you know
filters and you did a thing a really
funny thing about uh
filters and all that what are your
thoughts on being yourself like the
truth is i know i would have a lot more
followers if i did videos twerking in a
bikini or like exposing my body but it's
just not me and i've
i've been teaching kids for a really
long time so i i really
like take pride in being a role model so
[ __ ] followers like i i rather always be
the genuine like good role model um and
just catching a little bit of the hype
from being on these podcasts and getting
the messages like i try not to care
about what people think but it is hard
being like a sensitive empathetic person
and seeing all these hate and then i
have to remind myself i'm like i dare
you to get on stage and tell jokes in
front of correct thousands of people
like you can just as drake once said uh
trigger fingers turn to twitter fingers
right and now everyone's tough and they
got twitter you know 200 um
your thoughts i agree with with everyone
um i mean
we need to understand that on the
internet we're not going to post our sad
days we're not going to post us crying
you know like you're not going to post
you're basically only going to post your
good days um you're only showing your
wins exactly so be your authentic self
that will take you anywhere um i mean
even with the phone call with you
yesterday i was telling you
that's the only thing you have to be
because nobody is like you nobody is you
and you just have to realize that once
you realize that everything else comes
just so easy so you don't really
care about what other external forces
are coming into your way as long as you
truly have connected to you right
figuring out who you are and who you're
not uh and yeah reality is for all of us
we would get so many more followers if
we were to
you know just be
like 98 of them because i was actually
considering getting some lip done and
stuff like that just to kind of look
better but i don't know you're telling
i'm just gonna be myself you know but
it's all definition it's all what better
means to you right it's all about um
again what does better mean to you to me
better means to be my authentic self to
not have my lips done to be how
my parents brought me here and mother
nature brought me here just connect to
nature right
um so you cannot be natural unless
i'm not against it they do what they
want
i just think that it's a deeper issue
that we're trying to
suppress so yeah you want your lips to
get bigger because you want to look
better but what is it that you don't
like about it and yeah your lips are
just the trigger but what's inside you
that you need to figure out it's much
deeper than just your external things
that you're doing
so um well said young lady so yeah i
think it's all about figuring out who
you are and who you're not but wow
we're going to wrap up in the next 10
minutes